what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time while while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
paulina evilova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
in the house she is now 21 years old
she drank her first alcoholic beverage
last night amazing
life guys i am not 21 for everybody
who's like oh my god she's 21 i'm not
she looks 21 though gorgeousness ever uh
don't forget that
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five block five has three products you
can buy and sell crypto you can deposit
crypto and take out a us dollar
loan or you can deposit crypto or stable
coin and earn up to eight point six
percent apy
in an interest-bearing account
no-brainer go
check out blockfy.com lunch money
i'm an investor in the business i sell
the board of directors i'm a big fan i
use the products
i absolutely love block fi and you will
too
i'm pretty sure that little intro about
block fight is like in my dreams i think
i've absorbed it to the point
okay i might create a song for them i
don't think they want you to all right
let's go what's going on
we're gonna do this in 15 minutes today
ready set
rock and roll economists are warning
that america remains in a deep downturn
and is running a serious risk of a
worsening recession that will last at
least
another year about half of the national
association of business economics
members
expect us gross domestic product won't
return to its pre-pandemic level until
2022 what do you think
well i mean half of economists what did
the other half think
so i mean 2022 at the earliest sounds
about right i don't i
seeing what's going on in new york with
everybody i mean these restaurants are
gonna
suffer a lot of these stores already
closing permanently i don't know what's
going to happen
so my general thought process is that
the economists
don't have a great pulse on this what i
do know though is
uh there is a lot of damage on the
horizon
based on the actions that are being
taken today i think we'll talk about
that in a minute
um but on top of that uh part of the
issue
is that um the stock market's up and the
economic data is not good
so it's kind of masking how bad the
actual reality on the ground is because
stocks are up
and if you keep pumping trillions of
dollars into the economy that's what
happens
i feel like right now america has like a
face full of makeup
and then everybody's like wow it's so
great it's so pretty and then when it
takes it off it's like
oh crap
i did not expect that i could do
economic analysis
uh using uh female makeup uh tutorials
female makeup is just makeup well no
there's male makeup and females there is
no male makeup
you can use regular makeup yeah but
there's also male makeup
what is it uh plug my friend jeremy
he started a company called made man
made man
made man or made men uh-oh yeah okay
they have they have
uh i don't think you need to separate i
think it's all just makeup
they just don't call it makeup but it's
makeup all right what's going on next
jerome oh my god i almost called him
jeremy jerry powell
jerry powell jerry powell you were gonna
do that one more time
jerome powell set to deliver a
profoundly consequential speech
changing how the fed views inflation he
will speak
thursday during a virtual version
of the fed's annual jackson hole wyoming
conference
he is expected to outline what could be
the central bank's most active efforts
ever to spur inflation back to a healthy
level
don't get me started if you go back
to the mid 70s in the 60s and into the
70s there's high levels of inflation
there was unemployment
at double-digit percentages the dollar
was being weakened across the board
there was tons and tons of issues in the
economy paul volcker
who stepped in as the fed chairman two
months in he decided that he
was going to do the hard work he was
going to basically say look we are going
to return to a stable economy
the short-term pain that we are about to
experience based on my decisions is
worth it
and what he ended up doing was he ended
up actually
uh increasing interest rates he got rid
of inflation
he did the hard work uh there was two
recessions that he oversaw
two of them before we got back to a
strong economy
but the strong economy ended up setting
the stage for the 80s and into the 90s
and so what we are about to do is the
exact opposite of what toll volcker
did it says while the average consumer
might find it absurd to want to raise
the cost of limit
living central bankers and economists
see too little inflation also as a
problem
it often reflects a slow-moving economy
with a low standard of living
on top of that the accompanying low
interest rates give
policymakers little wiggle room when
crises happen and there's need to loosen
the policy
what ends up happening is uh economists
today which by the way
jerry powell mr jerome powell himself is
not an economist
he's the first fed chairman in 40 years
that's not an economist
no he comes from a legal and private
equity background so his hit generally
what he's doing is actually very good
for the private equity industry right
it's inflating asset prices
um but with that said uh there's a
culture of interventionism which
basically means it's human nature
something's going wrong we can't just
sit by and let it happen we have to do
something do something do something if
everyone wants to intervene and do
things
but what ends up happening is these are
highly complex systems let the free
market rain
leave it alone yeah but that could mean
a lot of economic pain for a whole lot
of people of course but the short-term
pain
ends up creating a more sustainable
stronger
long-term economy that's the whole
problem is
what they're doing is it's like saying
uh to a drug addict
hey you should get off drugs and they
say
yeah but just give me one more hit and
then
i'll start working on it and what you do
is that bam they take the heroin
right and then all of a sudden they're
actually getting more addicted to the
drug they're not
working towards a recovery and so what's
the best way sure they should go cold
turkey
and by the way i don't know if that's
the best if you go go cold turkey from a
drug addiction what happens is
you go through withdrawal there's like a
two-week period it's super painful
it's it gets more not that i know that
much but but eventually you come out of
that and you end up being better for it
that's the same thing like an economy we
gotta get off the addiction
guys if i ever wanna make anthony mad
i just say one word inflation
no just kidding by the way i know the
rules of the game
i benefit from inflation i'm just
calling out the nonsense that
uh the people who are getting hurt are
the people who don't know the rules of
the game
so like i'm just calling it how i see it
go ahead ready
yeah jpmorgan will have staff
cycle between office and remote work in
a move that may
remake wall street workers in jp
morgan's corporate and investment bank
will cycle between days spent at the
office and at home
keeping the ability to work remotely on
a part-time basis
so that's interesting summer fridays
every friday well but it's interesting
because
for me it's like okay well what if like
i go in
i come back or i go in i get coveted i
come back bring it to my family then
like i go it's just i think that's kind
of amazing they're gonna be testing us
oh like every time you go in i can only
imagine that they're gonna be testing
they're gonna be taking temperatures
doing all that kind of stuff oh
i mean look this is the new reality if
you want people to go back in the office
you're not going to bring everyone back
so i
i saw a meme that said uh isn't it weird
how we used to like get dressed up and
go to an
office for eight hours and work where
other people like watched us
all day it's kind of weird right what's
next
um all right so what we got today
is peter thiel backed lidar company
luminar
nears 3.4 billion dollars
it nears a 3.4 billion dollar deal to go
public via
a spec this is the kid who uh at 18 they
gave him 100k out of the
teal fellowship really yeah i think this
kid got a 100k
that was like a fellowship so don't go
to college instead do this
and like what's he 25 now yeah 25. so
seven years later
he's basically taking what started out
as a 100k grant as a teal fellowship
uh and he's got a business that's now
worth 3.4 billion dollars
wow so one teal fellowship seems to be
working
two even better is a 25 year old kid man
good for him i love wow so the startups
technology which uses lasers to create
real-time imagery of the physical world
is deployed in cars and trucks it has
about 350 employees and appointed former
investment banker thomas fenimore to be
chief financial officer in july
he's moving i mean three point four
billion dollar merger with blink check
company
gore's metropolis wait can you tell us
why spax why is everybody doing us back
now
so basically the traditional ipo process
costly takes time and there's a bunch of
pricing risk
so basically the bankers end up getting
the best deal and then you miss out on a
bunch of upside
um a faster way to do it in cheaper ways
to go direct listing but you raise no
capital so it's basically just hey just
get me listed
a spac can actually help you um kind of
be the
the best solution in some cases so what
happens is there's a listed company
that's on the public market
they buy a private company and it takes
the private company and now
gets them public because it takes all
the assets and the financials of the
team
into a public shell and now all of a
sudden they're running that public shell
so it's in essence a way to get the
company public
and when these happen the publicly
listed entity changes their name to the
private company's name
um and it's just a faster way to get to
the public markets
make sense makes sense all right what's
up with palantir
leaked palantir s1 shows company has 125
customers after 17 years
so the company's customer base is a
so okay sorry volunteer has precisely
125 customers as of the end of the first
half of 2020
palantir notes that the customers from
different parts of the same government
department
or company are considered separately
so that's interesting and they they
worked so here's my question about
palantir
i get it they have such large entities
they're working with
what happens if one of them pulls out i
feel like well the average deal size is
only 5.6 million dollars
right so basically they're doing over
half a billion dollars so but they only
have 100 you know whatever com
customers but each deal is worth 5.6
million dollars so
at the end of the day if you lose one
customer it's only 5 million yeah but
look at that the company's top three
customers
together represented 28 of the company's
revenue in 2019 and its top 20 customers
represented 67
yeah i mean that doesn't surprise me
well of course there's going to be a
distribution right there
the smallest customers are going to be a
lot of them your biggest customers are
going to be all right are you excited
for volunteer to go public
yeah look i actually think that palantir
is a very interesting business
uh in terms of the way that they built
it and we don't know very much about it
so the s1 obviously
discloses some of that but it'll be very
interesting to see once they start doing
quarterly reports how the business does
cool i like it all right speaking of the
us air force
has flying cars look at how cool this
looks
that does not look cool that is so cool
it looks like that's waiting for a crash
the us air force wants flying cars and
service leaders recently watched one
take flight in austin texas um
so the vehicle has 18 independent
electric motors and propellers
it kind of looks like a mini helicopter
has floats for amphibious
amphibious landings and can be flown
without a pilot's license that just
asking for trouble right there that's
super cool is it
yeah you just said it wasn't cool no i
mean like the amphibious part
amphibious means what uh i can land in
the water
oh cool so it probably can go land and
water i think is actually the definition
of amphibious
like an amphibious vehicle means that
you can drive right off the land into
the water and then it's like a boat
this basically can probably do the same
thing it's pretty soon like a jet ski
and a helicopter combined
[Music]
all right see ya so would you ride an
air and
yeah really um
i would definitely try it out i don't
know if i would
what okay what do you time for a joke
all right what joke you got for me what
do you call them this is not a good one
what do you call a man with a rubber toe
a man with a rubber toe stubborn
no now what roberto
okay we're going to work on the jokes
maybe we'll get you a new website
people said that for my birthday you
should have gotten me a joke book
i am the joke in your life ain't not the
truth
all right guys i like your sweatshirt oh
thanks
that's a very nice one today bang bang
see you tomorrow
okay th this is this is where we end the
show because
dancing is not what we need to see on
the internet all right guys that's it
for lunch money see you guys tomorrow
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
go and check out blockfy.com lunch
monday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five so go check them out there's a link
in the description that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends